the problems of the world of his
heartbreaking it is heartbreaking but if
you know the Koran the first words of
the Koran the very first I believe are
something like in the name of God the
gracious and the merciful praise be to
God Lord of the Worlds the most gracious
the most merciful master of the book of
judgment they're saying graciousness and
mercy is what sathru they repeated it
twice in the first page it's you we
worship and you we ask lead us to the
straight path the path of those you have
blessed not those against whom there is
anger over a misguided so anyone who
knows this beautiful religion this
beautiful that was the height of
civilization in the 13th century the
Arab civilization that we had that gave
us mathematics and science everyone
knows that at the root of that religion
the two most important words are then
God is gracious and God is merciful and
we trust to that God to deliver us from
this misunderstanding that is doing
these terrible things that is hurting
people God does not want people to be
hurt God is gracious God is merciful and
that's what I have to say